in the McMurdo Dry Valleys in Antarctica
there is a five story tall waterfall
that is leaking a blood-red substance it
also happens to be home to one of the
most alien life-forms we have ever
discovered five million years ago when
things were a bit warmer and the sea
level was a little higher a whole bunch
of sea water flowed into this part of
Antarctica later about three million
years ago the ice started to form again
and glaciers slid over this pool of
seawater also in there was all the
microbial life that had been living it's
a little like if you took your goldfish
bowl sealed it up put it in a bag and
left it there for two million years I
don't think you'd like what you found
when you looked at the kit but due to
some fissures in the glacier some of
this trapped pool is able to flow out
and the place where it starts to flow
out is blood Falls the waterfall turns
out to be blood-red for the same reason
blood is red it has tons of iron it and
when it gets exposed to the air I turns
what is genuinely a blood-red color so
you know you notice it when you walk by
it you're like white gray brown white
white white brown gray white boy Oh
blood red it's a five story tall
blood-red waterfall the source of blood
fall is thought to be this brine lake
something that was so salty that it
couldn't freeze that's at least 1,300
feet under the ice and a couple of
kilometers away it's even more amazing
is that the microbes that were trapped
there
they're definitely still alive alive
chill Micucci the Geo microbiologist
which is an awesome title to have
published the definitive paper on blood
falls when they sampled this red sludge
they found that there were at least 17
different microbes living in it how they
survived turns out to be a pretty
complicated answer and we're not
absolutely sure but it goes something
like this they're trapped in there so
they need to be
able to recycle their food source what
they think they do is that there are
these sulfides collections of sulfur
oxygen and iron and these microbes go
and break them apart and they eat the
sulfur and are able to pull oxygen out
of this iron sulfide and essentially
when they do this the iron fits back in
because there's a bunch of free-floating
iron in there and just remakes little
tasty microbe snacks it points to both
the extreme conditions that microbial
life can live under and starts to help
us build our tools for finding those
conditions on other planets but I think
we can acknowledge that right here on
earth there is life that is wondrous and
weird and more alien than we really
could have ever imagined subscribe here
and watch more videos here and if you're
a geo microbiologist I will totally
subscribe to your channel actually if
you if you're a biologist in general
I'll probably subscribe to your channel
or a geologist if your scientist let me
know subscribe to your channel